what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to kevin
samuels but before i start
do not forget to leave a like
a comment and ring the bell hit that
subscribe button
i'm trying to get to 20 000 subscribers
so each and every one of you is really
helping me get
to that goal okay let me
oh wait i clicked the wrong one
do you guys think kevin samuels would
come on come on my channel
being around probably black side of the
family i do see the difference
in for lack of better words how a black
mother
raises their daughters that grows in a
single home versus a hispanic movement
yeah let me let me let me let me step up
from this bullet for you right now
because there are all kind of bullets
coming at you right as soon as you said
that different
here's what it comes down to
hello hey how are you
i'm good how are you man my wind is high
how old are you 29 i'll be 30 in june
so what are we talking about um well i
joined your live
later but um i just wanted to give
from a woman's perspective um in
agreeance with you like maybe like i
heard the other young lady saying a lot
of women
find your um your
delivery to be harsh and it's just
i saw you on shade room and literally i
cannot go into a room where there's not
like if i meet up with my friends if i
meet up with my sisters your name comes
up inside
god damn so it's been funny i have four
children and i'm happily married and
my husband and i sit and listen to you
and uh you know we like
most of it's laughter i think the whole
uh you have three lives and you're on
live number one i think that was like
maybe a week or so ago we were in tears
laughing
i've been with my husband since i was
21. and
from a woman's perspective ladies i just
want to say
he's not lying to you and i sit and i
ask my ques my husband
long before even hearing about you very
gruesome
and personal personal questions and i'm
very honest with myself about
what i need to change about myself or
what do you like about this and so
listening to you i'm like maybe i just
think like a guy
or is kevin just not all that wrong
and more right but it's women don't want
to hear a man telling them and
uh growing up with a puerto rican mom
and then being around and then my
father's black but then being around
my black side of the family i do see the
difference in
for lack of better words how a black
mother raises their daughters that grows
them a single home versus a hispanic
movement
let me let me let me step up from this
bullet for you right now
because there are all kind of bullets
coming at you right as soon as you said
that different
here's what it comes down to and i don't
blame black women for this
no but i don't blame black women
you don't is it's we're not used to
seeing
black men in a position of respect
responsibility and being right
the things i say are controversial
more so because i'm a black man
um versus if they were like some of the
things if i were
dr phil or joe rogan or somebody else
will be more easily acceptable
than coming from me and i can't change
that
but the fact of the matter is we need to
be able to change that because it needs
to become more commonplace to where our
women
can see our men on the same level as
they see anybody else
um so yeah i take a lot of stuff
i don't yeah i haven't
noticed that too much um
in terms of
like in the date like i'm thinking
dating right obviously i only worked in
corporate america for a year and i
i worked at like the widest company and
also
i was the only girl in the office so it
wasn't like
like i don't have a ton of experience in
corporate america i have one office
right
but what i'm talking about is like in a
dating marketplace
when i think back to college like the
black guys and the white guys
it really i didn't see a difference
in the number of like girls they would
get
and even i think the black guys probably
got more because they were athletes so
they
tended to be like taller and like more
athletic
i know my name is everywhere now
sorry to cut you off have you ever
considered i've heard you i think just
tell another
lady you purposely have the delivery
that you have like you want
you want to step on sometimes you that
it like it's necessary
it's necessary at times it's necessary
i don't do anything without a reason so
i'm never just doing stuff to be
provocative or right it's always thought
out
so um most people don't recognize that
if i'm doing something
just just give me a second i'll get
there uh if you watch my content
sometimes it may seem like i'm all over
the place like what the hell's he
talking about
next you know 13 minutes later i tie all
the points together
my ultimate point is to get women to
understand where the very men that they
want are coming from
and get men to understand that just like
we got bad information women got bad
information too
and in order to get anywhere we're both
going to have to give each other a
certain amount of grace and mercy
and good faith because we're building
this thing while we're flying it and
we're all broken
and this is where i really agree with
kevin samuels and it's actually the
the reason that i started my channel and
it's funny because i swear i did the
opposite because i really wanted to talk
to young women
about dating advice because
i think that if more women realize that
20 of the guys get 80 of the girls
and your real odds with a guy like that
because when you're a girl
you're just always told he doesn't
deserve you
you can do better
um like i don't think
i've ever told a female friend he's only
hooking up with you because you're easy
i don't know if i could
i don't know if i could um
but sometimes like
that advice would be helpful to women to
make better decisions
with the men that they choose to date
because if you realize you're one of
many
you may you move different and because
a lot of times yeah that's all i'm gonna
say is you move different i'm not gonna
i'll let them talk and good faith is
more important than anything else
and if if both men and women in our
community can start looking at each
other
with as human beings with a fundamental
respect
like every other group of people we're
far more willing to give each other a
chance versus just writing each other
out
so that and selflessness is the word
that i would use ex
like if both of us are selfless with
each other then you have no
nothing but room to win he's doing
everything for you and you're doing
everything for him
and that's what's lacking heaven
i would take and that's and and that's
like
uh that's a 201 or 301 class i'm just
taking one i'm taking english 101 right
now
okay simple respect can
you get respect for me and can you smile
at brothers okay we got history 101
english one-on-one
uh science for non-majors just the
basics this is the basics
we get to our coursework and our and our
degree plan
after we get the basics out of the way
because we didn't get it and there's no
way for adults to get that
um and i'm not willing to i'm not
willing to write off an entire
group because we didn't get it where we
should have got it
right no i agree and i think there's a
huge even talking to my friends like i
said i was just out having drinks with
my sisters and the men and the women
brought your name up and i was like
just saw you maybe the end of march on
um
on shade room and then i saw you more in
april and i was like okay follow him and
see what he's talking about and
we've enjoyed it but then i hear even my
own sisters
they didn't like the delivery but when
they i started breaking it down what
you're really saying i'm like you have
to get
you're it's stinging because he's
stepping on your toes he's he's talking
about you like what you're
saying to the other person but a lot of
times
women think they want marriage they
think they want the relationship but
really you want a
wedding you want a person that's going
to take care of you but you
don't really want him telling you
anything you don't want him to tell you
what to do you don't want him
really as a part of your life i've even
had friends joke and say i want the
husband but get me a
separate house because oh i had somebody
i was gonna bring on the show for that
and it's a very it was a i did
what was it i've heard that too
you know this is something that kevin's
show
actually opened my eyes to a lot is
i didn't realize when you get married
that
immediately like the man's in charge of
the finances or like typically right
like if you're going traditional
and i never really thought about how if
i make more money
that it's going to be harder to date i
don't know just like random stuff like
that his show has really like opened my
eyes to
gary hilson um that she was in in the
news recently thought about
i could be married and live separately
and you know what
look um i'm not foolish enough to
believe that we're going to go back to
mayberry rfd they're going to be
different kinds of relationships
yeah but at the end at the end of the
day we got to be together in some form
so that's what i'd like to hear him talk
more about is the different kinds of
relationships because
you have to understand that technology
is evolving
and so how and opportunities are
becoming more and more for women
so how is that going to impact
relationships in the future like
obviously like
marriage has broken down but i don't i
wouldn't say that's necessarily just
from women like making more money and
having a career
um so i don't know i just i'd be curious
to hear his thoughts on that
it's funny that you've seen me
everywhere that's crazy
well thank you for watching i appreciate
it i didn't know who you were
go ahead i said i was saying thank you
for watching
i was about that okay
that was one of the most pleasant
exchanges i've seen him
give that was fun i left in a good mood
didn't feel bad for the girl at all or
want to ring her neck a little bit you
know what i mean let me know in the
comments
what you guys thought about this episode
don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification like ring the
bell
you know